welcome to this episode of middle ground
straight A's versus flunking students a
huge thank you to our sponsors curiosity
stream for sponsoring this episode for
those of you who don't know curiosity
stream is an amazing subscription
streaming service that has a ton of
great titles from documentary and
nonfiction filmmakers so make sure to
stick around to the end to find out how
you can get 30 days free and also hear
about some of our favorites but first
here's the episode the idea of being a
straight-a student I can't relate to
because I'm always wanting to go out
like I have that I do or like there's a
paper that I have and you know there's a
paper but there's a skateboard I'm um
definitely keeping with all the work
especially when you're like me and you
procrastinate a lot sometimes I just
don't understand and I just don't get as
much help as I would want well first of
all so I was like preppy doesn't really
go outside of like their house kind of I
got a 4.2 GPA exiting high school I
worked my ass off see yesterday's I want
to get a nursing degree but if I want to
I'll go to medical school and become a
neurosurgeon um of course I'm
disappointed in myself that I let myself
fail but I'm not gonna beat myself up
for one letter grade I'm Randi I'm 15
and I'm going into my sophomore year I'm
grace I'm 16 I'm going into my junior
year hi I'm tansy I'm 16 and I'm going
into my senior year of high school and
I'm also a freshman in college I'm
Cooper I'm 18 and I just graduated
senior year I'm Nadia I'm 15 and I'm
going into my sophomore year of high
school
I'm 19 and I'm going to my sophomore
year
[Applause]
I believe my grave defying my
intelligence I definitely think my
grades define like how smart I am like
that's the biggest like security point I
have like a like as a person and I've
just always been smart and like I always
want people to think I'm smart I believe
like that's really true for me I believe
like some subjects will enable you to
show your intellect in some way shape or
form like math but I do think that
grades can't show someone's intellect
whether it's you know understanding the
concept or enabling themselves to you
know grasp a subject I didn't step up
because I don't believe because I'm not
comprehending the concept of geometry or
algebra or poetry that's not making it
dumb or that doesn't not make me less
smart of a person I think also people
have different styles of learning and a
lot of times schools try to put you in
this mold of how they how they want you
to get a certain grade and people aren't
always made for that mold and it's
really important that I think schools
take into account that not all people
are willing to learn by reading a book
and so to measure that based on a
certain letter is I just feel like so
like superficial it's it's looking at it
so one-sided I am because it kind of
like shows off my hard work and all that
because I come from like a family that
really didn't have anything and being a
straight-a student allows me to pay
homage to other hard work and so it
makes me really proud to be able to you
know honor them into some sort of way of
course like if you try your hardest and
if you do all your work you do all your
homework you're good of course you're
gonna get good grades just because
you're not comprehending it doesn't mean
that you're not gonna get the good grade
yeah you're my struggle but with help
and hard work you're gonna get there
eventually so I definitely think there's
two sides to hard work itself because
we're
hard that can mean like studying and
like working super hard to better your
own skills but you can also work super
hard to cheat and work super hard to get
answers to tests and work super hard in
that manner but at the end of the day it
still might get you a good grade on
either side from the most part a lot of
people tend to cheat on tests copy
homework and depending on how the
teacher might grade like the grading
system 85 percent of your class grade
could be homework you cheat on all your
homework assignments you have a B right
there if you're the type of person where
you can put your mind to something and
never give up on it
you'll get that grade I've had a seventh
grade teacher my English teacher and I
tried my hardest in her class meanwhile
I didn't know NSA me that she was
full-blown racist okay so I was sitting
there in that classroom working my
hardest making C's knowing I can make
eight and it like put me down so much
with my self-esteem it also like depends
on oh you're like personal sampling with
actual teacher themselves if you if you
clearly if you're provoking a teacher
you know like I do it all the time like
they're not gonna like you I've learned
that but that's a lesson in itself
that's like an experience of learning is
that you need to make friends with your
teachers don't want to give you a good
grade if you're friends with them
there's some concepts and I'm going back
to like personal like experiences in
eighth grade I couldn't get exponents to
save my life
I went to tutoring you know I stayed
after school had parent-teacher
conferences because they thought I was
being a bad kid in that study they
thought I was failing on purpose
it took me my freshman year of high
school to realize like oh my god this is
so simple there's certain learning
blocks that you can face within yourself
it doesn't necessarily have to be
teachers it doesn't necessarily have to
be like social problems it could be all
in your head and if it takes that one
roadblock it will like stop everything
are you
you're great no I'm not self-conscious
because I know there's a lot more
students are in my same boat who aren't
dumb they just have trouble
comprehending certain subjects I can't
relate to the other side
so I've never gotten straight A's ever
like I've never been like on the top in
the top of my class
I've always been struggling or I've
always been just in the middle just yeah
I mean ever since I was younger I was
always in an extra class to like help me
with my work like my elementary school
they had a gifted program I was never in
the gifted program there are some ways I
can relate like I'm still I'm still I'm
working hard I'm still making sure that
I get the best rates that I possibly can
but I'm not I'm not like them I don't
stay up so during the morning study I
don't stay up to 3:00 in the morning to
do a project I'll say it to probably
like one and I'm like you know what I'm
done like I need my rest because the
next day I'm gonna go to school and be
all tired and be all frustrated and then
it's just it's too much so being like
the idea of being in tradition I can't
relate to because I'm always wanting to
go out like I have that I do or like
there's a paper that I have and you know
there's a paper but there's a skateboard
I'm gonna yeah I'm out like the fun I
have just hanging out with friends and
just like doing whatever we want
whenever we want she's so much better
than like wow I just gotten a like you
know okay so I can definitely relate to
the idea of being a flunking student
because I feel like there's two types
there is one type that doesn't choose to
do the work and then there's the other
type of where I cannot understand this I
need help and I relate to both because
there's some times where like I've
gotten a grade on a test like I failed
it and there sounds like I'm not gonna
retake that if that's too hard why would
I waste my time and then there's times
where I'm like oh my freaking God like I
cannot understand this for the life of
me I need help which is fine because
that everyone's gonna get things like a
drop of a dime you know there's some
people that do there's some people that
don't I can 100% relate to you guys
because I know what it feels like to be
sitting at a desk at 11:00 at night and
wondering how in the hell am I going to
finish this and luckily I've been able
to push through but I can see how
someone couldn't I fully relate with all
of you guys because at some points I
have questioned like maybe I should just
go in and not study for the test
I I don't I feel that like just some of
you guys don't like a
relate to as much as you think being a
flunking student like flunking a lot not
just one class and you guys still have
four point knows I am lucky if I pass
the two point no in a way I see your
eyes is pointing like when you say
there's two types but no matter what
type of functioning you are you are
always going to be characterized with
the stereotypes that a flunking student
is not smart they just don't do their
words they're lazy I'm not gonna say
that I'm an F student and I'm proud of
it of course I'm not talking about being
a student but I'm not gonna push myself
down because I'm an F student you're
right I can't relate to that idea of
being a flunking student and having
those eyeballs on you in a certain way
and I I wish that I could because I want
to I want to understand what that's like
it's the same with you guys yeah at the
same time like do you guys have like the
nerd stereo outside walk up to somebody
who's like like one of us right and like
we don't know you and you be like yeah
i'ma show you soon it really Oh so you
sit in your room all day you don't you
know what kind of your room no matter
what there's always zero types you can
be completely different but you're
you're still gonna be characterized as
that's or answer your time like cool
I do like school yeah are there other
things happening in your life that
distracting yeah a lot of stuff at home
I struggled with my grandma dying and my
parents splitting up and all that isn't
good for my mental health especially
when I'm struggling with certain
subjects and certain topics and tests
and people my parents help me with my
work
um I won't say my mom helps you look
like my English work my math my science
when I was doing theater she would help
me memorize my lines she would help me
write the essays to like certain
directors of the show she pushes me to
do it myself which I'm glad about but
there are some times when I'm like can
you help me she's like I don't know what
either I'm like okay that's fine you
know my parents don't like writing my
essays for me yeah you know it's like my
dad you know he dropped out of college
you know it's not like he's gonna be
helping me with like my AP stats
homework yeah but you know it's like he
will I think they helped me do my work
in the sense of like they keep me
diligent they are in a sense like
instilling me with the right qualities
to write those essays I feel like my mom
looks at my paper and she's like girl
this I knew math like I aim like my mom
she can't help me really and neither can
my dad so cuz when I get back from
school my mom's leaving and go to work
my dad works all day and when he comes
back home he's tired and then I have to
take care of my little sister even when
my mom comes back she comes back they're
like 2 in the morning and she still sees
me up I have to do that on my own so I'm
certain subjects my dad could definitely
help me open I take auto shop he's
automotive tech well yeah exactly
when it comes down to like actually
doing it with normal subjects he says to
me like you need to figure it out
because at the end of the day one day
I'm not gonna be there to help you at
all
I'm like well I have no clue okay I got
it I'm gonna put something down and like
I'm gonna turn it in so when it comes
out don't be yeah don't be surprised
like I want to be an automotive tech but
then I would like to own my own business
off of it I know they're like they want
to see me aspire to what I can be it's
hard to like steer people to a different
direction to like but this is what I
would like to do
I do believe that I do these are the
grades I get especially for the ones
that I am failing such as English I'm
not putting my hunter percent into the
class I'm probably giving like 50% 75%
if that but for the grades that I am
getting good at like my film production
class I'm giving all I'm focusing more
on my extracurriculars and I am on my
primary classes which is my fault it's
nobody else's fault I am putting myself
in a position where I'm letting myself
like these classes I feel like I deserve
the grade that I get because I know I
could get a better grade but I choose
not to because it's like the subject to
me like it doesn't really click with me
why am I gonna sit here and put all of
my effort to something that you want me
to put only to get like what you want to
see that's as long as I'm passing that's
all I really care for I mean I've worked
my ass off just so that I can get that
good letter and as much as I would have
liked to just focus on film I knew that
in order for me to you know at least
have self-esteem and feel like I was
being successful I had to do both
and I don't know if like that was the
greatest thing to do I don't know if
that was the best decision but I worked
as hard as I possibly could and I feel
like I do deserve the grades that I got
I'm not ungrateful for the great ticket
and I'm so happy with the grades I get
but to be honest sometimes I do just put
like 50% of my work in and I don't try
my best but I still do well on the
project I don't think I deserve that
because think about the kids who are
like working diligently on that project
trying to get a good grade but just
because I was able to finish it out hope
it out last minute or my teacher likes
me or I'm a good student overall I don't
think that that's a fair advantage to
have yeah I don't believe that I deserve
the grades I get because I've had lots
of group projects where it wasn't just
me and it's always people there was a
time where I had two slides big sized
project and I did most of the work but I
only have like three slides for two
other people to do but they never did it
never turned it in and it just dropped
my grade completely didn't you tell your
teacher yeah she didn't care she says
you have to talk with each other after
school
and I do that like can we just all agree
that teachers really do like I don't
know how to explain it or foot it yeah
like the pressure of teachers like you
can have a really chill mellow teacher
and your worst subject and it'll make
you work harder and you can have a
really strict teacher and your favorite
subject and then like make you slack I
yeah for sure I definitely wanna go to
college I think I want to go to law
school and go into like the law
profession I started doing debate last
year and I can't solve so me and my
parents haven't really had the college
talk but I've had the college that I
want to go to sit on since I was like 10
but yeah I want to go to college for me
because I want to become a better dancer
and then I also want to perform and then
afterwards make my own dance studio and
all that stuff but I want to be a
performer and I can't be the level a
performer I want to be without being
able to go to college yeah I think I do
it for like another reason to like I
have to go to college because of my
career choice but at the end of the day
there's kids in countries that get
killed for reading books that to travel
across rivers and jungles just to get an
education and I think sometimes we do
take that for granted I want to show
that education is very powerful the
wanting like I I don't exactly want to
go to like college but I want to go to
trade school so it's kind of like an
after school after you know but it's
like I want to go and experience being
in a different place like not being in
high school people coming from all these
different places like it's so like it's
so different like you know so I kind of
feel like the opposite side I like what
you guys are saying I want to go to
college but the reason why I want to go
to college is because I feel like it's
the thing that like make me feel more
successful and like it's still like my
own desire in my own want I want to go
to college mainly just so I can like
make myself a good life and make myself
a good career another thing is I don't
always like think that because somebody
goes to college I'd not no offense to
you but like it doesn't always come the
way you think like just because you go
to college doesn't make you exactly the
most successful
I mean like I want to go to college to
make my family proud
I come from an it from from a family
where like we're all Hispanics not many
of us have ever even thought about going
to college the thought of call it's not
of high school graduating high school is
really difficult like you graduated high
school so I'm like I don't want to waste
my opportunities I'm not going to take
these chances for granted like I am
going to make myself proud in my family
proud oh yeah I'm not one of those
naturally like smart people who can look
at a book and instantly know I think our
education system is very like set into
these like molds of how you need to fit
not everyone fits into the mold of a
high school there's so many things that
defines smart and it's not just being
book smart or street smart it's smart
just knowledge and I have a lot of
knowledge and I know a lot of things and
I value that knowledge which I think is
really important also to being smart I
mean it's how you use the knowledge that
you have I am smart no matter what like
just because I'm getting an F on the
test doesn't make me I can be book
smart
I'm also street smart like I know my way
around I know my pace and I know where I
need to be yeah to say you're smart is
like something that everybody should you
ever say in themselves because no matter
what even if you don't feel like yeah
I'm the smartest person in the room you
might you might not feel like that but
you're smart to yourself like you you're
the one you're the only person who knows
how your body works and how you feel
you're educated on yourself you're
educated on the people around you your
friends you know so it's like you might
not know something about her that I know
that doesn't make you like dumb compared
to me like you know what I mean like
everybody's still smart in their own way
I feel like everybody has something to
bring to the table no matter what like
at the end of the day schools just like
the first start of her lives you know
we're go stepping out we're learning new
things and not to say that grades are
like insignificant but at the end of the
day they should really shouldn't like
put such a hold of you where you like
cry or you're depressed or something
like that or makes you feel dumb is such
a dumb word
it's like why I like why do we use it I
think all of you are like so freaking
smart I don't give a about it you
know you're you're 2.0 like I don't care
you know it's like right you're right
yeah you know it's like the it's the
penis the person that matters and I hope
that all of us actually know that you
know because that's that's what's gonna
define us in the end that's what's gonna
make you successful oh that was super
endearing I love that episode see I was
a straight-a student no comment this
episode dealt a lot with education the
importance of grades and if you want to
learn more about education or see what
it might look like in the future check
out a series on curiosity stream dream
the future specifically an episode
called school of the future it's
narrated by Sigourney Weaver it examines
how we might be able to use technology
to make learning better for students for
those of you who don't know curiosity
stream is an amazing subscription
streaming service they have a ton of
titles like these from documentary and
nonfiction filmmakers from around the
world and for three bucks a month or
twenty bucks a year you can get
unlimited unlimited unlimited access to
all these amazing films plus for you
good humans out there if you sign up at
curiosity stream comm slash Jubilee
promo code Jubilee you can get 30 days
for free I literally will do anything to
not have to leave my bed so I watched on
their website you can watch one like
Apple TV Roku Xbox like any of these
devices taking over the world right now
people it's really cool check it out and
thanks for watching
see you next time
you